vamos a ver si podemos aprender un par
de cosas acerca de las secciones cónicas
primero que nada uno se pregunta bueno
qué son y por qué se llaman así y quizás
ya puedes reconocer algunas por ejemplo
voy a escribir aquí todas las cónicas
que conocemos una de ellas es el círculo
muy bien otra de ellas es la elipse la
elipse la tercera de ellas es por
supuesto la famosa parábola la parábola
y finalmente también conocemos la
hipérbola ok
entonces también cuando yo aprendí de
estas cosas pues yo ya conocía por
ejemplo el círculo pues es la figura
geométrica que nos enseñan desde la
educación básica
quizás la parábola porque ya conocía un
poquito de álgebra y demás sin embargo
bueno tenía quizás idea de qué era la
elipse pero yo no conocía que darle
hipérbola entonces por qué porque es que
se llaman secciones cónicas para empezar
estas son las cuatro secciones cónicas y
la pregunta es por qué se llaman de esa
forma ok primero que nada para aquellos
que no conozcan algunas de ellas voy a
dibujar cuáles son las secciones cónicas
primero el círculo pues es más o menos
esta figura ok quizás ese fue el peor
círculo que he hecho en mi vida
pero ahí tengo busca si lo hago bien
digamos este es el círculo esencialmente
son todos aquellos puntos que distan lo
mismo de un punto fijo entonces tenemos
aquí un punto fijo que éste es el que
conocemos como centro y de iu y damos
una distancia así que el círculo es el
conjunto de puntos que existan que
distan lo mismo de este punto que es el
centro la misma cantidad que a esa
cantidad le llamamos radio ok
simplemente es el círculo que ya todo el
mundo conocemos ahora bien vamos a
dibujar una elipse que en términos
digamos coloquiales pues no es otra cosa
más que un círculo apachurrado verdad
como como aplastado por algunos lados y
bien las elipses no necesariamente
tienen que estar digamos acostadas
también pueden estar rotadas y demás
pero bueno estas son las elipses y de
hecho puede uno demostrar ya lo veremos
después que el círculo es un caso
particular de la elipse y el círculo es
es es justo la figura que hace que el
mundo gire es literalmente no así que
por ejemplo cuando hablamos de una
parábola
en realidad bueno quizás sí ya sí ya has
visto algo de álgebra puedes reconocer
muy bien esta figura verdad que tiene
digamos como forma de v que igual
también no necesariamente tiene que
estar de forma vertical podemos dibujar
una parábola
así muy bien y esta forma bueno esta
parábola es muy fácil de reconocerla con
una ecuación
la equis cuadrada verdad es la gráfica
de la función x cuadrada ahora la
hipérbole es la que menos se conoce pero
déjenme déjenme hacer un intento por
dibujarla o de dibujar unos ejes digamos
aquí están nuestros ejes y voy a tratar
de dibujar también unas rectas que se
van a llamar así notas de ahorita digo
porque se van a llamar así entonces
tengo dos rectas que se llaman así into
estás y son a sin todas porque la
hipérbola se parece muchísimo a las
gráficas cuando crece así que
esencialmente nos dice que las hipérbola
se parecen mucho a esas rectas
se van pareciendo mucho digamos de forma
justamente a sintética es decir para
cuando nos alejamos mucho de la de la
del centro de este centro ok
más o menos se ven algo así ok
estas estás hipérbolas se parecen mucho
a las rectas y de hecho tengo que decir
que la hipérbola es este estas dos hojas
estas dos líneas rojas es una hipérbole
no se parece bueno se parece un poco a
la parábola pero la la propiedad que
tienen las hipérboles es de irse pegando
mucho muy muy cerca a estas dos líneas
por ejemplo otra hipérbola pues puede
ser esta de aquí
y podemos dibujar este hipérbola
esta otra hipérbola el punto es que a la
larga se vayan pareciendo muchísimo en
estas líneas azules que son las asín
todas muy bien entonces seguro ahorita
te estás preguntando muy bien están
padres los dibujos están muy divertidos
pero porque se llaman secciones cónicas
vámonos a eso
vamos a dibujar primero un cono muy bien
vamos a tratar de dibujar un cono
digamos aquí tengo
mi base superior
tengo un lado del cono
tengo
otro lado del cono
ok fue un muy buen dibujo
ok y bueno pues esta es la base más o
menos espero se vea la idea de lo que es
el cono déjenme dibujar bien la base
muy bien ahí lo tienen ahí tienen
ustedes un cono y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es interceptar este cono con
distintos planos entonces el primer
plano que quiero dibujar es este un
plano digamos que es ortogonal a este
eje y al eje de este cono digamos si
usted es el eje el eje vertical digamos
estamos pensando que éste conoce
extienden todas las direcciones muy bien
este cono no está tronco simplemente
sigue creciendo hacia arriba y hacia
abajo muy bien pero si aquí está el eje
entonces nuestro plano que estamos
dibujando ahorita es ortogonal a ese
sale entonces por ejemplo ahí tienen
ustedes este plano que si lo cortamos
bueno aquí pasa por atrás del cono muy
bien y esto al interceptar el cono este
plano me va a dibujar una curva que se
encuentra aquí muy bien digamos esta es
la parte de atrás y lo que nosotros
estamos viendo es por ejemplo si
viéramos este plano desde arriba si
viéramos el plano desde arriba
digamos aquí está nuestro plano y la
curva en donde interceptó al cono
simplemente es un círculo es un bonito
círculo muy bien entonces al interceptar
este plano más perdón este cono con un
plano que es ortogonal al eje nos dibuja
un círculo ahora qué pasaría si nosotros
cambiamos un poco el la inclinación de
este plano digamos que ahora ahora lo
dibujamos de esta forma
muy bien
este plano el plano anterior digamos que
lo rotamos un poco
y ahora terminamos el dibujo esto pasa
por acá atrás
y ahí tienen ustedes este plano por
supuesto todos los planos se extienden
en todas las direcciones verdad no son
solo cuadrados sino se extienden por
todos lados muy bien entonces si
nosotros dibujamos eso ahora nosotros
tenemos una nueva curva que se dibuja
aquí
digamos como algo así
y luego lo demás se ve por atrás
entonces nuevamente si nosotros viéramos
esa curva que formamos al interceptarlo
desde arriba lo que nosotros veríamos es
algo así que es justamente una elipse
entonces al rotar tantito el plano que
nos generaba un círculo
ahora tenemos una elipse entonces voy a
utilizar este punto de aquí digamos como
como de anclaje y voy a seguir rotando
nuestro nuestro plano hasta por ejemplo
el caso en el que es paralelo digamos a
esta inclinación del cono muy bien
digamos esto es esto va por atrás del
cono
y lo tienen
un poquito más grande en nuestro plano
ahí lo tienen lo estoy dibujando por
atrás ahí quedó
saleh espero espero se empiece a
entender muy bien que es lo que estoy
haciendo yo sé que es un poco complicado
debido a que son muchos dibujos encima
pero bueno ya que tenemos este plano
dibujado así y que es digamos paralelo a
esta inclinación entonces esta figura
que nos genera aquí simplemente es
justamente algo de esta forma verdad
algo así
esta figura muy bien y entonces lo que
vamos a ver es justamente una parábola
justamente una parábola esto es lo que
estamos viendo sobre el plano morado
entonces fíjate muy bien lo que estamos
haciendo es teníamos un círculo y al ir
va variando digamos la inclinación de
este plano nos de unir una elipse si
seguimos inclinando e inclinando
inclinando hasta llegar a esta
inclinación que es paralela digamos a la
inclinación del cono entonces la elipse
se rompe completamente y se forma una
parábola esto es muy muy bonito de
interpretarlo vámonos finalmente a qué
pasa cuando seguimos y seguimos
inclinando esto y digamos que tenemos
algo algo digamos así
algo así
este sí está bastante grande ok esto va
por atrás
y ya sale muy bien sale entonces tenemos
justo este plano naranja entonces ahora
lo que vamos a tener no es una parábola
porque además acá arriba también
intersecta si estamos de acuerdo
entonces aquí lo que se vería es más o
menos algo así
y ya por atrás se ve esta figura y acá
también se ve la misma
más o menos como la misma
entonces lo que estamos viendo aquí
ahora es más o menos algo así
y también se ve algo por acá arriba
entonces no solo llamaríamos la elipse y
convertimos la elipse en una parábola
sino que además también al variar la
inclinación de nuestro plano llegamos
justo a lo que son las hipérboles y aquí
está la razón de por qué se les llama
secciones cónicas esto se puede
justificar matemáticamente y veremos eso
como están relacionados todas las
cónicas con mayor profundidad pero en el
próximo vídeo o en los próximos vídeos
ahora que ya sabes qué son y por qué se
les llama secciones cónicas hablaré de
sus fórmulas de cómo reconocerlas o por
ejemplo dada una fórmula como graficar
las en el plano nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo